- This is a map of what
the Americas looked like
at around the year 1750.
And as you can see, it
was for the most part,
divided as colonies by a
bunch of European powers.
Most prominent is Spain.
You can see in this peach brownish color,
it had control all the way
south as modern-day Chile
and Argentina and all the way as far north
as modern-day Texas and California.
You also see significant
control by the Portuguese
in what will eventually be Brazil.
The French have at this
point some territory,
especially in North America
and in several islands
in the Caribbean and
the British, of course,
have control along the east
coast of North America.
And they also have several
islands in the Caribbean
and the Atlantic.
As we fast forward 100 years,
we're going to see a dramatic change.
Notice roughly a hundred years later,
most of what used to be
these European colonies
have now achieved independence.
In other videos, we go in
some depth from 1776 to 1783.
You have the American
War for Independence.
You see on this map now the United States
is an independent country.
From 1791 to 1804, you
have Toussaint Louveture
lead the revolt against French control,
eventually gaining independence
and establishing Haiti.
From 1807 to 1830, you have
a series of revolutions
in Latin America, many of which were led
by Simon Bolivar, who was a
Crejo, or Creole, Venezuelan.
The term Creole has many
meanings in modern-day language,
but in this context, it refers to someone
of mostly Spanish descent who
was born in the New World.
And Simon Bolivar plays an active role
in achieving independence
from Spain for Venezuela,
what will eventually
be Columbia and Panama,
Ecuador, Peru, and the
country that will eventually
be named for him, Bolivia.
So there is an interesting question here.
What led to all of these revolutions?
The map that I showed you before,
that colonial map of the Americas,
these colonies had been in
place for several hundred years
before these revolutions.
Why did all of these revolutions happen
roughly at the same time?
Well, one overarching idea
is that as we enter into
the 1700s, you have the
intellectual movement
known as the Enlightenment.
There were many authors
and many publications
involved in the Enlightenment,
but perhaps most famous is
the Encyclopedie in French,
or Encyclopedia, which said
the intent of collecting
much of the scientific
and political science,
knowledge of the time and is considered
one of the central texts
of the Enlightenment.
And it was a series of articles published
from the 1750s all the
way until the 1770s.
And to get a sense of
it, here is an excerpt
of an article by one of the authors,
Denis Diderot, considered
one of the primary actors
in the Enlightenment.
"No man has received from nature
"the right to command others.
"Liberty is gift from
heaven, and each individual
"of the same species
has the right to enjoy
"it as soon as he enjoys
the use of reason."
And so when we get into the
Declaration of Independence,
written by Thomas Jefferson,
he borrows heavily
from these ideas of the Enlightenment.
Now, the Haitian Revolution
was partially inspired
by these ideas of the Enlightenment,
but they were also helped by the fact
that France was undergoing
its own revolution
at the time and it was not in the position
to exert strong control
over a far flung colony.
The French Revolution
lasts from 1789 to 1799
at which point Napoleon
Bonaparte takes control of France
and starts the Napoleonic Wars.
Napoleon tries to keep control
of what would eventually
be Haiti, was an incredibly
valuable resource.
It produced a good chunk of
coffee and sugar in the world.
It was incredibly profitable
for the plantation owners
and for France as a nation.
But between the ideas of the Enlightenment
and the French Revolution,
the slaves of Haiti
led initially by Toussaint Louverture,
were able to overthrow and
set up their own nation,
which is the first time
that this has happened
from a successful slave revolt.
This is a map of the empire
that Napoleon establishes
at its peak and as you can see,
you see France, but he's
able to take over much
of modern-day Germany,
Italy, he goes to war
with Portugal and then
eventually Spain as well.
Both significant colonial
powers in South America.
So it's in this context,
you have the Enlightenment
as we get into the 1700s.
You already have the example
of the American War for Independence.
13 colonies being able
to declare independence
from one of the largest
powers at the time.
Then a successful slave
revolt to establish
their own country against
another significant power.
And once Spain and Portugal
are fighting Napoleon
coupled with the ideas
of the Enlightenment
and the examples of the
United States and Haiti,
it inspires a whole other series
of revolts in Latin America, many of which
were led by Simon Bolivar.
And so by the time we get to 1850,
much of the European
imperialism in the Americas
has come to an end.